You wouldn't care
that you are sleeping
with your step-daddy's son?
When the mum drops the baby,
is it not related to my man
that's all doing up
7 inches?
Hi friends, welcome to
my brand-new Netflix show
where I bring my friends
to go head to head
to debate on their
favourite Netflix shows.
And guess who decides
the winning goose?
Yeah, you're right. It's me.
So in today's episode
we have...
-Rachel Bada.
-And Amanda Char.
And they will be
going against...
Rheanne Murray
And Mimi Missfit.
That's my crew.
We're confident over here.
I don't know why
you're talking
-because we're gonna win.
-Amen.
I like your confidence.
You guys don't even know
the case!
The case that
we are bringing
to the court of law...
-A whole briefcase.
-Innit
As I unlock this...
You got this
with your nails?
Everybody shut up.
So the first case
that we have here...
Nella, please.
I can't take
the anticipation.
OK!
Can everybody say
Sex Education.
So we're going to be
discussing Sex Education.
But before,
in the court of law,
you guys
have to solemnly swear...
-Not on the Bible.
-To tell the truth...
and nothing but the truth.
So everybody put
your acrylics forward.
So everybody swear
to put their best
argument forward
in the court of law.
I swear to put
my best argument forward
in the court of law.
God is not listening
to you people!
That was really long...
to remember.
It wasn't that deep.
Right guys,
you guys are gonna need
your case files.
Ladies first.
-Oh wow.
-Here's your case study.
In this court of law,
Group A believe
that Adam is
a better boyfriend for Eric,
while Group B defer
and believe that Rahim
is the better boy for Eric.
You have to say Rahim.
-Rahim!
-Rahim's a better boyfriend!
Adam is a better boyfriend
suited.
Even though
he did have his past,
everyone can be forgiven.
No.
The fact that he actually
genuinely likes Adam,
he's actually his boyfriend,
he claims him.
Rahim the better boyfriend
because he knows himself.
We're tired of building
these men up
to know who they are.
Know who you are when
you present yourself to me.
I know who I am.
Sorry, don't come to me
and be bullying me
in the beginning,
then later on
tell me you love me.
Ain't got time for that.
I don't have time for that.
We're not in…
We're not in primary school!
We're not in primary school,
we're not doing--
Order! You've had your time.
Every time I do this,
everybody: order!
I'm gonna give you guys
a chance to have
a stronger argument.
Yeah, 'cause it was week
and we won.
There's no weakness.
There's no weakness
in my court.
Adam is the better lover
only because the love
might be toxic,
but y'all know toxic love
is real love.
-It's not!
-Yes it is!
Yes, it is.
And to go on top
of what she's saying,
at least he's claiming Eric.
And the thing is I feel like
in general they have
the deeper connection,
right?
They have
the deeper connection.
-That's what really matters.
-It's his boyfriend.
We stand by what we said
because at the same time
I don't want a man
to come to me half full
-'cause my cup is very full.
-Wake up in this court!
Rahim used to write poems.
Poems!
What kind of guy ever?
Judge Nella,
who's the winner?
Are you guys going to speak
through the whole show?
-Maybe!
-Judge Nells!
The judge has left
the court.
I don't want to be
your secret as well,
also because I'm a hot girl,
you get me?
From the arguments that you
guys have presented to me--
Make the correct decision,
judge.
I think it's
my court of law.
Yeah, it's your turn
to speak. Go on, babe.
Don't let them bully you.
What I liked
about your argument
is that you mentioned
that the guy had like
a little bit of toxicity
inside of it.
Everybody, put your hands up
if you've had
a toxic guy in your life.
We kinda like
the toxic stuff, don't we?
You people,
I liked your argument
because I like romance.
I like the idea of romance.
Put your hands up
if you've ever had
a romantic boyfriend.
Actually, yeah.
Roses are red,
violets are blue,
I wake up in the morning,
all I want is you.
So I feel like a romantic
man is always a whim.
We need a man
that knows himself.
When a man
doesn't know himself,
he'll be in the club
popping bottles.
His account is withdrawn.
If a man doesn't even
know himself,
how can he even come
and get to know you?
The results are in.
The winning argument
after many deliberations
is Group...
B.
I like to win, win, win!
Don't be haters!
I just wanna thank my mum,
I want to thank God, like...
Alright guys,so we're gonna
move on to case number two.
Is it OK to get
with your step-sister,
based on the fact that Otis
and Ola get together
while their parents
are also dating?
So we were against it,
because at this rate
if the mum's with the guy
and she's pregnant...
Pregnant!
I mean, out of respect
for your mother
I think you should step back
because if you now have
a child with a guy
are you not all going to
be related?
Is it not gonna be like
a whole shebang?
On top of that, I feel like
your mum's at a certain age
where it's hard
to find guys.
So in the case of should
my step-sister be with--
You're wasting your time.
I'm telling you
it doesn't really matter
because at the end
of the day,
they were together before
the parents were together.
So technically
they were just classmates.
It's not my fault
that the man
has now decided to get
with my girlfriend's dad.
That had nothing to do
with me.
Why should I--
So Rheanne,
what do you think
about sleeping with your
mum's boyfriend's son?
You know what, yeah?
Exactly, I'm a libra.
It's my birthday soon.
I'm indecisive, you can't
ask me those questions.
That's a weak argument,
my love.
They're not blood related
so it's not incest,
but we have to keep it
a secret.
Like we can't be going
to church saying,
"Yeah, that's my uncle and
my brother and my sister."
No one will know that me
and my boyfriend
are in a relationship
while my mum--
I feel I support
my teammate.
D'you get it? I'm for it.
Do your thing, love is love.
What you're trying
to tell me is
you wouldn't care
that you are sleeping with
your step-daddy's son.
This is why I know
all of you are mad.
All of you are mad.
They are not related
by blood.
It does not mean anything.
Do you know what's so funny
and bear cute?
When the mum drops
the baby,
is it not related my man
that's all doing up
7 inches?
Every night, I'm in my room!
And you as well!
You think, "What is this?"
"Me, I'm balanced
equilibrium."
Yeah!
When you said you would
leave your boyfriend, yeah,
because your mum is going
out with his dad, yeah,
I don't think that's true,
love.
Let me tell you why
I don't think that's true.
You met him first.
I did, but my mum, she's
the one that pushed me out.
Can I ask you guys
a question, yeah?
No. In fact, it's for you.
Your mum's dating
your boyfriend's daddy
whilst you're calling
him Daddy, right?
But he's about to be
the daddy
to the pregnant baby
in her belly.
Means she's got two daddies.
Hell, no.
God forbid!
It took me
some time to realize!
Girl!
At the end of the day, guys,
this is everything
we're saying.
Everything you lot are
saying is kind of irrelevant
because--
Let me tell you why!
It's the shoulders
that you have right now.
Because they're not together
no more
at the end of the day.
That's not the argument
that was brought forward
in the court of law.
Yeah, they haven't
split up, right?
The court of law is
is incest OK?
But the parents split up so
you wasted your soul mate.
That's not the question!
Could I have a drum roll
please?
No, I'm not drum rolling
'cause we already know.
I think...
-Thank you so much, friends.
-The winning argument is...
Team B.
-What?
-Team B?
-You're being biased.
-I'm not.
At 16, whoever I was with
at 16,
I don't even know his name.
I left him on Facebook,
know why?
It was at a stage in my life
where a guy would be like,
"You're pretty, I love you."
A guy would come
and be like "I'm in love."
Yeah, Group B, you won.
Be clapping,
you can't be sly!
We clapped for you!
Alright guys,
so the last case.
Who's the most toxic boy
in Sex Education,
Adam
or Anwar?
So Group A, who are you guys
going to be defending today?
-Adam.
-The first man.
And Group B, what is
your opening argument?
Well, we believe
that Anwar--
I object.
I'm joking!
Adam is toxic,
but when he went away
to the army and stuff
and he came back,
I feel like he found himself
in the army.
Like he kind of calmed down
a bit,
like he kind of
mellowed out.
We believe that Adam
is definitely more toxic.
I've never met a bully
that hasn't been
like traumatized as a child,
so I feel like, you know,
he obviously comes
with a lot of baggage.
And he's also
very physical as well.
The other guy's
not really physical.
Like he's definitely
more toxic.
Yeah.
Case closed.
Did someone mention
anything about gossiping?
Yes, so that's the
assumption I was on.
Uncle likes to gossip.
What's so toxic
about gossiping?
What?
Along with the gossiping,
he also insults his friends,
like in front
of other friends.
And you know what
they say about people
that do the insults.
Like it's not a joke,
do you get it?
They really mean it.
He's the kind of person
that will throw acid on you
and then help you look
for the person
that threw acid on you.
So basically
you guys brought up
Adam's childhood trauma.
I've grown up
and I know some people
that have had the most
traumatic childhoods
and that basically
has kind of like
shaped them into being nice.
The nicest people.
Whenever you meet
the nicest people,
they have
the most traumatic stories.
So that's not an excuse
as to why he toxic, girl!
It's not about
his experience though.
It's about how he deals
with the experience.
I feel like people
that are traumatized
either become
really, really done out,
or really, really great.
It's either one
or the other, innit, so...
It's true.
Can everybody say "Balance".
Balance!
In this life.
Even in this season,
now that he's got with Eric,
there was a point where
he was gonna fight someone
and Eric was like, "No,
no, no. Keep your calm."
So he now has someone
who's helping him
like maneuver this calm.
This Anwar guy has no one.
No one's stopping him.
He's just unviolent.
That's a good point.
Who are you?
Who sent you?
-These kids are how old?
-16.
Right. Of course
they're gonna gossip.
We all thrived
off gossip at school.
My point is
the insulting your friends
in front of other people
and making your friends
for this small.
Yeah, I just feel like
Anwar is more toxic
in general
because he doesn't show
any development.
He hasn't shown any change,
any growth.
He's getting worse.
Can we do a drum roll?
No, because if you say
that they win again...
It's rigged,
it's actually rigged.
Judge Nella!
The winning argument is...
-Don't do that.
-Yeah!
Group A!
But we won anyway.
Two out of three,
we still won.
So that's what matters.
The whole violence thing
is something
that can't get over
because it's like
if you're that violent
at a like a teenager stage,
you're gonna take that
into your adulthood.
This one is just toxic
for fun and games now.
Like you know when
you're the it girl in school
and you just wanna like--
You just "Yappa, yappa,
yappa."
"Yappa, yappa,"
you just want to maintain
like your hierarchy.
Like the biggest bullies
in schools,
like you know the ones
that were talking the most,
where are they now? Where?
-Scary!
Scary!
This is the end of today's
episode on Sex Education.
So over here
we have the winning team,
Group B.
But massive round
of applause to Group A.
Don't give them
a round of applause,
they gunning for you.
If you guys wanna see
more of us
talking about
our favourite shows,
getting a little bit heated,
you know, a little bit
cheeky in there
then make sure
you guys stay tuned.
That's how it works.
Period!
Why do you guys
think that Henderson
deserves the death penalty
more than Grandma?
He's a male,
first and foremost.
Oh, it's true.